spooky season is officially upon us who
needs a little bit of Sacrament you need
some Sacrament I do what can I say but
now an excellent day for an
[Music]
exorcism so Exorcist believer is a new
Exorcist film that will make you think
of imagin Dragons by the title go ahead
try to tell me you
didn't liar it's directed by David
Gordon green who directed the 2018
Halloween Halloween kills and Halloween
ends I guess he was like I guess now
I'll take on The Exorcist I can sum up
this film with one phrase which is
interesting idea did not stick to Ling
and execution as seen in the trailer at
the beginning of this movie the entire
First Act essentially is a missing
person these two little girls go missing
which is why I give this movie or the
trailer more specifically props for
honesty except for Ellen buron I'll get
to her in a second when watching the
trailer I remember thinking looks like
two different movies and it feels like
two different movies so Props to honesty
this time around they have two possessed
girls got to give the girls props I
thought the girls were creepy I will say
with the voices you could tell more in
this movie than some other demonic
possession movies that the voices were
dubbed it was it wasn't the voice that
was coming out of the person when it
comes to creepy possessed demon youth
talking some mad [__] I thought they
were standouts in an otherwise
forgettable film with two possessed
girls that now means two families only
it doesn't really it concentrates on
this widower this single dad and his
daughter and the other family is the I
guess we'll call them the who gives a
shits I think that's the actual name on
their mailbox the editing in this movie
was obnoxious too there was actually a
scene I thought was really cool was when
the dad is talking to the daughter and
over his shoulder there's the possessed
demon version of the daughter the movie
didn't make a big deal about it that's
what made it work that's what made it a
good moment I didn't notice it initially
then I start hearing gasps in the
audience and I was like oh there it is
so it it truly was a chain reaction then
the movie forgets about that has imagery
jump on the screen with a bunch of loud
noise that just assault your senses hey
are you okay yeah I think so it's like
you're trying to throw back to that
scene in The Exorcist when creepy face
flashes onto the screen while forgetting
one of the things that made that scene
effective the silence silence truly is
golden it's fine to let the scene simmer
in silence it's actually kind of what
makes it creepy or you can assault the
audience with a bunch of jump Cuts
people slapping the glass in front of
their jump scares jump Cuts you know
says this guy not jump Cuts jump scares
but you know what I mean and they
weren't just jump scares they were jump
scares to the 10th it's like no one got
the memo audiences are sick and [__]
tired of jump scares stop it stop please
no more jump scares but this is the kind
of script that lacks any and all Nuance
situation exists where the girls were
gone for 3 days instead of letting the
audience make the connection or not you
know those who make the connection cool
those who don't it's fine but it means
more to those who do make the connection
that Jesus died and Rose on the third
day Jesus was gone for 3 Days the girls
were gone for 3 days this script has no
faith in the audience so they have to
have a character basically walk the
audience there drawing it out and
craying for them after Jesus was
crucified he was gone for three days
like our
daughters don't know why I was compelled
to say that almost like I I feel like
there's a camera on me showing this
conversation to an auditorium full of
people in a movie theater anyhow let's
go didn't feel organic just came across
as awkward again with the movie having a
good concept that it didn't stick The
Landing to of the exorcism scene was
another one because it deals with a
bunch of different people coming
together to help these two kids out
bunch of people of a lot of different
Faith Saul saying their own prayers
which is a great concept no longer is it
in the hands of the Catholics no longer
do we watch an exorcism scene and go
what if you're not Catholic are you just
kind of screwed but it just felt like
there was were too many irons in the
fire I didn't give a [__] I was like who
are you why do I care have I seen you
before at all before this scene I'm not
quite sure what are you doing here then
the film ended in a way that I felt was
quite frankly very unfulfilling oh yeah
Ellen Burston before I wrap this up I
should talk about the fact that she's in
the movie kind of she's in the trailer
the trailer heavily revolves around her
she's in the movie for a little bit
until she's not it's a very 2023 kind of
situation she's a leg character Cameo
who's in this film for the sake of Cameo
and nothing else if you took her out of
the film entirely nothing would really
change anyhow generic Movie unfulfilling
ending and I'm not going to remember it
in T minus one day yeah I'm out of here
felt like a rushed sloppy generic
exorcism SLP possession film that we've
seen a billion times over all right so
the Exorcist believer have you seen it
what did you think about it or what are
your Halloween movie Traditions every
year what are the movies you got to
watch before Halloween over whatever
they are whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see
[Music]
more